Oh
this is displayer which as the name
suggests is an air display basically
these water vapors are coming out of
this machine there's a computer and they
stand here and whatever is on the
computer is projected into this air
display it's a pretty neat thing and you
can actually interact with the display
and move it with your gestures something
like this isn't necessarily going to
have a place in your home quite yet
right now displayer is targeting more
advertising maybe hotels restaurants
that might want to have a crazy venue on
the air and it's going to cost you quite
a bit of money around 15,000 when they
enter market in q2 or q3 of this year
but I've never seen anything like it and
maybe in the future you'll have one in
your home